all right life is beautiful is a
spectacular event so is first friday the
mint 400 and pine dining mojave events
is the force behind them all and here to
tell us more is sherry macy with mojave
events welcome hi how are you great
great to have you here so if someone's
not familiar who or what is mojave
events you know we are an event
production company we uh we take our
clients ideas and we we make it happen
you bring them to life yeah bring in the
life and you're involved with life is
beautiful such a spectacular event it's
known for its music but also the
culinary side of it is unbelievable that
you guys just announced some of the
restaurants and chefs that are going to
be there touch on that for us yeah so we
you know we've got over 70 plus culinary
vendors on site six different culinary
programs um you know restaurants from
the strip from
uh you know bar zazu with no chef nicole
um all the way to you know pizza tracks
like pizza like a pizza truck that you
can find at first friday and there's a
whole pizza section that life is
beautiful this year yeah this is a new
program we're really excited for the
pizzeria um
vincent over at goodpie he's our program
curator we have different pizza makers
that are going to be their local pizzas
that are going to be activating from 4
to 10
or before sell out but it really gets to
showcase our local talent and our in our
pizza community from you know yukon
pizza to pizza forte they'll all be
there one day being able to showcase uh
their their amazing talents i love life
is beautiful because you can taste all
these different restaurants and soak in
all that great music you're tied into so
many other events and one we were
talking about before we started was pine
dining people might not be familiar with
it what is pine dining pine dining so
the ellis fanny family christina ellis
she's had this great idea about being
able to bring local chefs from vegas up
to mount charleston it's a chef series
every weekend we just wrapped up the
fourth one with chef nicole as i
mentioned before it was amazing and uh
we are actually going to be releasing
more tickets um this week for the next
remaining three to four weekends and so
be on the lookout for those and this is
outdoors at mount charleston because the
lodge had the fire blaster a couple
years ago and then they're rebuilding so
right now they can go up you're eating
outside and esther's kitchen was up
there a couple weeks ago and so how do
people get a reservation for this you go
to the website mount charleston website
and you can get a ticket through there
and you can do either saturday or sunday
saturdays are more of a tasting event
and sunday's like a full-on sit-down
dinner um for like 75-80 people uh for
that session so it's great you have your
hands tied in so many great las vegas
events thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it thank you all right
jillian we'll send it over to you all
right